I'm Michelle Guthrie. I'm at Providence Equity
based in Hong Kong. I'm very interested in
this Davos question about in the geo political
issues will outweigh the economic crisis in
east Asia, and I don't agree with that. I
think that ultimately what matters to most
people in east Asia is their security in terms
of employment opportunities, in terms of growth
for their economy. And I think that they--,
I'm probably overwhelmingly optimistic that
the geo political conflicts will be sorted
out because of the intermingling of countries
and the, ultimately, the fact that everyone
wants security. So I'm convinced that as a
practical matter, even though we'll have bumps
along the way, that frankly everybody is going
to do the right thing. And, you know, that
the geo political conflicts will be sorted
out. But I think that the most pressing need
in east Asia is really setting the path for
future continued growth and integration of
east Asia into global economy. Thank you.